DNA, the basic molecule of life, is all about chemistry. Although the structural
differences between the base letters may look
small to you, in the chemistry world,
it does make a really big difference. These differences are what
essentially dictate which other chemicals can interact with.
For example, DNA is most commonly double-stranded. It's double-stranded
because each base letter can form a
chemical pair with another letter across from it.
In fact we call this basepairing and it
follows very specific rules. In fact see if
you can look a the image here
and determine what those basepairing rules are. Look
at the text boxes below, and enter in
which base letter can partner with the other.